another article you've written for your
site the cultural weekly calm is three
reason to entrepreneurs and artists are
the same and you say one they see past
the horizon to their makers and doers
not day dreamers and three they may
finish but they are never truly done I'm
curious though how does some people get
caught in that
daydreaming trap are some people just
born doers and then some people are just
born dreamers or is it a learned inertia
Wow do you know I've asked elite but you
do get things done don't you I mean here
you do you're gonna finish this video so
you know that you get things done you
know the dream space is really necessary
to create things at the end of the day
you have to have it you have to have the
dream time and you know we probably both
know many people who writers for example
who won't write won't write won't write
and they did a weekend afraid a novel
and it just comes out you know Arthur
Miller I said I wrote Death of a
Salesman in three days well of course
you didn't really he may have physically
sat at his old Remington for three days
typing it but he probably worked on it
consciously dreaming subconsciously for
years before he finally got up onto the
page so that dreaming time is very
important but some people just dream and
we all know people who just say oh I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that and they
start a lot of things and they never
finish them they never get them you know
really to a point of completion um
that's not the people that we're talking
to right now we're talking to the people
who actually get things done we actually
make things probably only 10% of the
population because the rest of the
population probably the constituents the
audience the market for the people who
actually finish things get things done
in this creative space and of course
there's no value judgment about whether
you finish or don't finish whether you
dream or make right we we all need each
other introverts need extroverts
extroverts the introverts creative
people need audiences audiences need
creative people cultural weekly is all
about a place where everybody can come
and share that and really what I'm
trying to do on that side with a lot of
amazing help from some of some great
writers and great thinkers and really
really loyal readers we're just trying
to elevate the conversation because
there's not a lot of great space to talk
about creative things and talk about
them in deep ways that are better than
sound bites that are deeper than a
thumbs-up thumbs-down and we're just
trying to find to model ways to have
conversations that have some depth and
variety and other levels of interest
other ways to look at things we don't
have an axe to grind we don't have a
political perspective we don't have a
cultural axe to grind or a creative
perspective other than the value
creativity to say cultures really
important to say that the cultural and
creative life that we live dramatically
affects the world that we live in and we
should talk about that we should have a
little place in a way to talk about that
it's all that we're trying to do on
cultural weekly and if someone would
like to contribute an article yes what
sure well you just you go to cultural
weekly calm and under about there's a
category called right for us and I have
a list of guidelines for people to write
and we do get unsolicited contributions
and we read every one of them and you
know often they get into the the online
magazine which we publish every week it
has to be about culture and creativity
so as long as you are looking at your
subject through the lens of culture and
creativity or it's about something
cultural or creative it doesn't matter
if it's present or past or future it
doesn't matter if it's architecture or a
painting or film or a theater or dance
as long as it's about the creative work
it finds us if we find a home in
cultural weekly and then I care that you
have a strong point of view and you
articulated well and that it's
fascinating because in the online
environment you have to keep people's
interest and it's got to be fascinating
and you've got to have a good lead and
you need a good image so people will
actually read it it's you know all the
same things as in a print magazine it
has all the same rules and audiences
will either turn the page or scroll away
quickly unless you keep their interest
there are many of your readers artists
themselves or they just appreciate you
know I haven't done a survey but I would
say it's probably 8020 I'd say probably
20% our creative people themselves
writers playwrights filmmakers dancers
visual artists poets we actually have a
lot of poets we have a lot of poets I
think I think the the article with the
most comments is a poem which is a
beautiful and hopeful thing in America
today something close to 200 comments on
a pump
but and probably the other 80% are just
people who love creative things and read
books and read poems and go to movies
and go to theatre and go to dance and
care about architecture and care about
art it didn't exist if there's just a
void it didn't exist with the shocking
thing is that that donate that domain
name existed right which was proof that
it really didn't exist
you